I've devoted my life to studying past generations.
Last year, I had a unique chance to work with my uncle.
Our job was to find old treasures for a school's history foundation.
He also hired a crew of students.
They signed a contract to work with him.
He was the boss.
The place was strange, though.
I dined on many things that I had never tasted before.
They had an unusual flavor.
We had been there about a month and hadn't found anything.
One day, I began to dig in the soil.
The ground's layers got wetter.
Soon I was digging in the mud.
My shovel began to get very heavy.
It felt like it had doubled in weight...
...because the ground had absorbed a lot of water.
Finally, I saw something in the mud.
It was an old knife!
The handle felt smooth in my hand.
I elevated it so I could see it better.
There was writing on it.
"It says it will bring good luck," my uncle said with a smile.
"Why don't you keep it?"
I put it in my tent.
The next day, we found many more things.
There were pots, jewelry, and weapons.
My uncle donated all of the things to a special committee.
Many newspapers wrote stories about it.
It seemed the knife really did bring good luck!